level direkt alter ok 13 14 alltag heft
das ist so eine geile oppermann zu einem
typischen legende und wir sind einer
geilen konstellation mit ludger gamon
crafter hallo
warum sagst eigentlich immer die epische
legende das frage ich mich schon immer
war ich keine ahnung ich habe es mir
irgendwann so spontan eingefallen ich
habe auch weiß ja nicht wie leute die
meinen sky den krieg verfolgt haben
da habe ich dann immer gesagt so silke
köpfe und dann wird irgendwann so was
habe ich sowieso ein robot gemacht
elektro denn keine ahnung ich denke so
was aus dann finde ich das cool und dann
nur halt nicht achtlos auch sonst apis
kacke ist es stein bei dir da oben auf
dem monster falle so schön habe ich
jetzt gemacht weil aber irgendwie gar
nicht nach oben
ja das frage ich mich auch ich dachte
auch die leicht nach oben ich habe schon
dinge in meinem in meinem haus stehen
ja und ich dachte auch die leuchten nach
oben so was was wir uns hier gedacht
haben wer erst mal so ich habe ja die
figaro
ich habe 32 level und ich wollte ein
bisschen verzaubern und ich wollte mir
ein miniatur carbon kanister herz holen
weil ich habe schon alle sachen uhr ich
brauche ich brauche also hast du auch
schon die bones ja die bei uns habe ich
eher dazu möchte dir was sagen ich habe
nämlich während des live streams eine
wird das skelett farm gebaut
ach so gut ja die habe ich aber schon
jetzt kann sich ja trotzdem mal zeigen
weil das so ja klar auf jeden fall
die sache ist halt nur wie kriegen wir
aluminium aluminium findest du rhum und
das ist auch mein mankel punkt ich habe
jetzt schon 30 leben ich so ich dachte
das kriegt man aus der farm aus dem ofen
irgendwie raus nähe das musste irgendwo
hin dass ein relativ seltenes erz immer
so wenn du zum beispiel gremmel siehst
weißt einer oberfläche ja dann ist das
manchmal so eisen gremmel travel travel
aber generell nach aluminium travel zum
beispiel was sie auch schon gesehen dass
die stadt noch ein bisschen gemacht das
gar nicht machen ich glaube ich eine
ganze doppelte couples darum gefahren
und dann wollte ich
livestream die machen und da war ich
schon gemacht so ehrlich ja irgendwer
hat die gemacht aus marmor und ich
wollte mich nicht wer das war
ich denke mal zombie oder so glaube ich
auch das ist ein bisschen soziale und
viele haben sich schon gewundert in der
skype konfi das möchte ich noch mal für
alle sagen programms haben ja eine stadt
pinkl grüner das heißt diesen der stadt
blau in den rücken gefallen und ich als
könig habe die beiden aus der stadt blau
somit ausgeschlossen was ein richtiger
ist dementsprechend wichtig ist weil das
wichtig durch gewinne sich absetzen
müssen wir uns eigentlich griff ich bin
im arsch der welt nicht außerhalb
ausgelobt habe weil ich übelst angst
hatte dass simon uns so mich töten und
24 schon live stream branchen übrigen
aufnahmefähig und ich werden veit
hundertprozentig verloren
weitaus höher bis zu 3000 locke fast ich
laufe ja okay gut
ja was soll jetzt noch sagen dass die
werden bei der königswall nicht
mitwählen
das was auch richtig schuld die sind
jetzt in unserer wir haben ja immer so
stadt konfis haben eine stadt konfi eine
todes konnte eine infocom viele ob
konnten und in der stadt konfis halt nur
statt blau und die sache sei die da sind
die branche sind da drin und die kann
halt alles hören und unserer stadt aber
die sind eigentlich mit stadt road
verbindet stadt pink na ja gesagt habe
ich da so ein bisschen angst ich will
jetzt nicht daraus kicken aus der stadt
conti aber da sind so interne
spielerischen probleme das ist relativ
hoch
ja das habe ich auch schon sagt wir
können gerne raus kicken was ich schon
gesagt habe
also schön und gut die haben ihre eigene
stadt jetzt gemacht aber ich muss sagen
das zeugt natürlich nicht von eigener
stärke wenn man sich mit dem zurzeit
stärksten mit der stärksten fraktion
unbedingt verbinden möchte finde jetzt
ist setzt ich finde das auch nicht so
ich meine es ist jetzt kein herber
verlust
das muss man so sagen viel spaß aber es
ist auf jeden fall so dass ich finde es
ein bisschen komisch dass die einfach so
die stadt verschwinden ja eigentlich aus
unserer stadt weg gehen weil eigentlich
ist es so dass man manchmal zu seiner
stadt
man ist patriotisch hier mal läutet man
erfreut sich seiner stadt und man man
kämpft und stirbt für seine stadt
so wird ihr aus dem euro in komplett
verbunden mit der stadt blau ich liebe
euch alle und die haut da einfach ab das
ist ja so eine sache
da muss man schon irgendwie dann
bestrafen irgendwie hin
ich kann jetzt zeigen wir die mob falle
funktioniert all the way
ja ich verzaubert noch meine tiefste
kapitalisten das freilich bin und ich
habe mich jetzt schön hoch gebaut und
zwar wollen auch vier levels dafür alle
teile habe ich jetzt verzaubert von
meiner de palma außer das display tja
okay ich komme hoch zu seehofers genau
ich habe nur kurz eben aktiviert so weit
ist deaktiviert ich baue hier wieder zu
und zwar habe ich so gemacht weil wir
hat das letzte mal probleme dass ich
gestorben bin dann alles explodiert bin
fast gestorben weil einfach die nonstop
gestern ist es wirklich so ist lässt die
mit redstone regeln wenn du denen hier
oben wirft so also du kannst du drauf
gucken dann muss ich noch eine lampe
machen also wenn oben der redstone aus
ist ist die mob alle an sie ihn an
genau aber bis vor hingegen die sowieso
noch nicht weil ich gerade eben erst den
stein reingemacht habe kann ich mir hier
einfach ein schwert an rausnehmen da du
kannst ja alles also alles was ihre
kisten es kannst du benutzen die so
lustig bist und so gut auf mich auch
nicht nur leben hab ich bei dir 30 was
heißt da hast du so kann es dann auch
schon also ich hab schon fünf stück
schon fünf stück ja gut das ist ja auch
das was mein nächstes ziel ist ich habe
mir alle sachen dafür ich habe ja glaub
ich sogar zwei mini mini mini a thür
herzen
nur ich brauche ja diese kugel ich
brauche aluminium das ist ja mal in
meinem ertl punkt und genau deswegen
möchte ich auch jetzt mal bitte erklären
wie man den schmelzofen benutzt ja was
soll ich da einen raum manchen
verzaubern noch immer internet weil da
er habe ich jetzt eben genug level
moment das man schnell das geht eher
eine last und zwar extra auch noch krieg
gebaut alles fertig gemacht und sagt
prof
ich habe aber wie viel weiß nicht
wieviel brauchst du da einmal raus
ja ja geil wenn du hast dann weil dem
braucht man immer ich wusste auch in die
hölle gehen höre ich ihnen das ist jetzt
die frage
das schöne ist du kannst mit dem ist
auch zum beispiel gold erz und eisenerz
verdoppeln halten
du musst nur einmal ich habe immer und
ich weiß wohl aber ist hier nebenan
also das ist ein bisschen fliegen ich
bin sofort wieder darunter herz wölfen
zuschauerwerte moment ich bin froh
wieder da das ist direkt hier in ihrem
erklären wie das verdoppelt und zwar
musst du die ärzte mit zig touch abbauen
habe ich etwas mit zilk ich weiß gar
nicht spitz tag mit super job weg die
ärzte schmelzen sich obwohl keine lava
drin ist so ok ich hab' ein lager
erreicht vielleicht zwei kanister hat
keine ahnung ich glaub ich hab gar keine
sache mit zig touch er musste jetzt
sogar kostenlos acht level nur das ganze
chillig weil das geht leider nicht mehr
diamanten aber bei aluminium geht das
zum beispiel das habe jetzt vier
aluminium auch hier eingepackt ob das
kann ich dann hier hinterließ so wenn du
hier rein guckt siehst du gar vier
aluminium auch drin da stand lara einmal
häftling messi war drin muss halt immer
recht ich glaube die kanister siehst du
was auch drin
und die sehe ich ja gerade nicht aber
damit siehst du hier für aluminium oder
eingepackt und die schmelzen sich so vor
erster denn die aluminium oder hasst ihn
vermisst und weil ich ja ich hab ja wie
gesagt so viel kabels angefangen und
irgendwo in der erde waren die dann okay
gut und ich habe hier auch schon so das
nennt sich in geschäfts gemacht sondern
dass man auf damit man weiß das aussieht
also sozusagen wie die außenhülle eines
so eine blaupause eine single ja warm
ein rechtsklick auf diesen schwarzen
tisch hier
welche tische auf den täter ja und dann
legt sich das da rein und wenn du dann
zum beispiel jetzt eingestellt du siehst
hier mithalten quasi diese nacht
aluminium es genau auf solche zeichen da
musst du hier oben auf diesen ausgießer
drücken von warten müsste es wieder
kleinbild da das heißt am 11 aber so
funktioniert das doch selber noch um ein
grad bringt er sowieso noch nichts dass
könig du musst doch für unsere stadt
ein bisschen seinen kämpfen muss wir
verschenken ich habe nie etwas geschenkt
was drin allerdings links leisten diese
mexiko essenzen du hast mir ich habe gar
keine existenzen von dir oder ich hab
grad gegeben
ehrlich ich kann mich ja gar nicht an
ich dachte du meintest immer nämlich
fach gewesen war
da habe ich gesagt ja doch so viele
ganzen dass eine listung komplett ist
das war auch gut da hat mein spiegel zu
statt geld kaputt gemacht dann hat mir
den einfach vier stück oder so gegeben
als entschuldigung für sein altes
mädchen getötet das waren die folge wir
friedensvertrag gemacht habe ich habe
jetzt alle drei müsste und das
vollstellen ich habe privat scale und
die andere aber hier muss noch den
pfosten alle rüstung ja ja gar nicht ich
habe nur hier und was ich habe ihn
allerdings kann er vor schlecht damit
habt ihr heft ich bin auch erst 6 das
heißt er ist aber ich bin sechsmal
gestorben und alle sind irgendwie
mittlerweile heftig auf gestorben sie
wollen das jetzt auch schon dreimal
gestorben alter eben zehnmal gestorben
als er kann ja ja das ist es ja das ist
ja wie alle stärkt also das heißt nicht
wie oft soll das ist ja normal weil das
ding ist alles ist eigentlich an hier
ist heftig gut die monster falle mit
einer ski zu benutzen oder midlife oder
rief dann geht doch so alles kaputt wie
schon im support debatte so geht es viel
besser warte ja ich hab schon wartest du
alles was ich ja alle außerdem ist wo
halt wenn ich aber vergiftet hier gerade
wenn du musst ja natürlich alles wandert
mäßig deutlich zeigt die auswahl wie ich
das mache und zwar deswegen ist auch
hier extra diese dieser abstand da
manche mops sagen wie du sollst einmal
nichts wegwerfen
du musst wecken uns sehr wichtig weil
ich töte alle mit einem schlag ja ja das
ist ja mit einer gleich auch so ach so
wusste ich gar nicht oder was hast du
für den export boom den diamond wixforth
diamondbacks water drei remis müsste das
diamond mäßig aus es macht man aus eisen
und diamonds und hier neben hast du ich
hab dir den müll statt noch gar nicht
gezeigt einen weg doch den den habe ich
in einer folge gesehen
ja weil abwehr kommt soviel möge
auswirft einmal alles weg dann ist es
weg schrieb xj dann ist das habe ich
doch irgendwo da ich hab das vw wie gehe
ich dann damit wie gehe ich damit um mit
dem mx wurde im rechtsklick auf laden
dann loslassen
beim mega hit hey ich hab locker 20
goldene äpfel heftig war es die guten
diese künstler in fünf dann habe ich
alle an kann sich ein flop kraft ist ja
ich wahrscheinlich auf 15 10 ab das sehe
ich hab das ich habe das ja nicht
gemacht habe auch viel gefunden einfach
und so ich war ein echter zeit lang viel
unterwegs
nur ich will mich halt immer mehr also
richtung krieg aufstellen meister lol
was mache ich noch für die scheiße bin
ich blöd er klar
also ich hab schon 50 leveln stehe ich
jetzt wird sie mit farbe weiter level
krieg doch sony 2 der song bottner
gerade alles egal
durch seite bleibt drin wave level
direkt alter ok 13 14 alltag hilft das
ist so eine geile oppermann er vor allem
wenn man dann oft geht dann geht man
einfach wieder weg und wie es absolut
willig aber man muss danach immer sonnen
sondern giants portman damit die
vergiftung einem nicht wehtut
also bei mir ist es egal mittlerweile
die skater doch wenn du die klassierung
wahrscheinlich auch verzaubert und sonne
also noch nicht aber es wollte ich auch
noch an ich wollte ihr noch kurz genoss
den müll schwerer kennst du wer hat euch
noch kurz die uhr das skelett farm truck
on two wheels of skelett kleinen moment
mal noch einmal an das ist so schön dass
ich spaß mal kommt er gar nicht weg
vor allem und jetzt kommt so langsam die
ep dann wieder das aber ich kenne das
jetzt
ddp 24 dann einfach so und macht so viel
spaß ich will mehr
wo bist du denn wirklich sie denke ach
sooo genau dass ich das jetzt damit
nicht hier keine sendezeit stelle
robo ach so was mir noch aufgefallen ist
damit du es weißt weil die kanister kann
man nicht auf seelen gebunden machen und
die verlierst auch beim sterben deswegen
ist es deswegen ist es so ich habe die
kanister zwar dünne und wenn ich dir
jetzt schon teilnehmen würde bleiben
mein herz auf dem hohen stand
ach so das heißt du würdest wenn du
jetzt schaden klingt würdest würdest du
nicht mehr weiter regenerieren als
zweiten flug shop dabei warte ich noch
immer müssen aber sonst das direkt am
eingang aber wie mich nämlich hatte
da habe ich dennoch die elektrik star
lotta stars und ich habe unseren
friedhof erweitert noch weil ich sehe da
war voll alle sterben er hatte electric
da shmeggs elektrik mechanik elektronik
hinweg denn ich war ja da legte ich habe
neue elektrik essenzen aber nur so wenig
wie mache ich denn noch mal warten
normalen jetzt muss man ganz christoph
diamant dick & magic ist es so und ich
muss mit craft was kann man überhaupt
aus quarz warnung was gutes jemand was
man aus schwarzem schielt
doch klar ein quatsch hielt man kann ein
computer machen daily day light sensor
ein schild ein never cropscience bird
magic sense ich hab so flippig machen
jetzt richtig viele stars richtig bock
ankommt muss dann alle machen hier mit
dem flugzeug starb entschuldigung kam
block war zwar nicht immer
ich kann mir 99 electric dass man
meistens nicht so also die farm ist
natürlich bei weitem nicht so effizient
wie das was wir zu hause haben aber man
braucht die mutter skelette nur für die
köpfe oder für die knollen dieser halt
geben und deswegen reicht ja einfach
hier aus jetzt packe ich die sache noch
in einen müllcontainer und dann komme
ich direkt zu dir
1 2 3 4 5
das ist aber echt geil dass ich das
alles so direkt löscht quasi ja so muss
das auch sein weil der komplex ich hab
wohl recht überlegt tue ich alles in die
kissen aber da kommt so viel scheiße ein
bisschen hoch weil ihr natürlich von den
zuschauern gesagt wurde
wenn irgendeine eisen rüstung zum
beispiel kommt dann kann man die auch in
diesen schmelzofen wer auf reisen raus
zum beispiel ehrlich das wäre dann
wieder geil wenn das gäbe das werde ich
gleich mal austesten alter kommt schnell
ich war grad im boden drin egal schnell
ich war gar dem boden drin wie er seinem
opfer lässt
heft immer darüber ob ausgebrochen so
heftiger ok ich hab' volle leben dass
dazu aus weil das so schwarz war
wie aber das allein bis ausgebrochen
irgendwie können sich auf pforten die
bot moha der macht mir direkt
zweieinhalb jahren obwohl ich eine
verzerrte erregt denn anhand alter das
schon mal die stadt fast gesprengt wurde
kommt es doch ganz ist alle standard
machen hier wird heftig viel gemacht und
so deutschland bruneck ich zeig dir das
nicht mehr
das dumme ist bei uns nicht auf einen
posten dann tut mir leid ich muss immer
so weit laufen vom einfall unserer
ausgangs portal ist so weit hinten im
arsch der welt dieser scheiß posten ab
hilf immer wie mache ich das denn jetzt
töten
ich bin ein einfacher bürger kämpft du
musst mir helfen
das ist doch eine gute tat als
königspaar schreien und weinen schafft
das wo ist hier der boss joop ich
schaffe das ja irgendwo läuft ein
skelett darum ist noch keiner
naja gegen wir uns glücklich schätzen
lassen kein polster aus dem rahmen ob
boskoop sind ultra und die
entschuldigung and one i mein halt der
mine schwertes noch nicht verzaubert
deswegen ein bisschen doof schuldig
bekennen dass die panik
man muss erst mal alle töten bei uns
kommt der server zum lenken also er
macht die maus einfach alter direkt 30
level fast 30 level insta das ist geil
oder laufen lässt mehr lohnt sich gar
nicht mehr zu holen ist alles ja dies
aus ach ja ich bin auch wieder voll
alter mann ist direkt voll direkt voll
so muss das sein direkt los
ein fall muss ich aber drin behalten
soll hp blabla in dieser folge machen
deswegen kommen bleibt ja ich komme
direkt ich bin hinter dir noch so vor
die hübsche wieder nicht gesehen wo du
jetzt bist wo ist nun seine reportage in
der stadt
es gibt nur eins es ist ein bisschen
außerhalb
ja ja ich bin drin das ist klar balda
drumherum
na ja das habe ich schon gefixt ich
ziehe lieber meine skela und was habe
ich gefälligst weiß doch gerettet
ich habe angst fabi war schäfer du ich
habs jetzt gucke jetzt hab ich da an
damit ich wenigstens in lava schwimmen
kann falls was passiert er sei doch froh
wir sind wie ich bin hier ein
ehrfurchtsvoll aller bürger und so falls
mir etwas passiert und nicht immer
fallen verliere ich nicht alleine sachen
rad
ich bin da hallo ich bin aber dahin
wirklich fertig du schlägst ist ein
schnauze lauf sehe mich ja laufen
unsichtbar das ist ein motto und zwar
hier habe ich ein skelett spongebob
gespannt aber wenn du dir so tötet ich
habe mir ein schwert auf fakten dieser
posten auf alt als ich mich so auf
klatsch ihr zweck
deutschland schneidet schwerter geklaute
war dieser mit medizin ihre eigenen
köpfe an alter etwas wasser ist es jetzt
hier wenn du das war mein schwerster
erstmal keine kohle kein das wohl sein
scheint eingesammelt hatte wörz im
moment noch zwei statt obwohl mir
eingesammelt was für 22 ändert 1 nein
ich habe nur ich schwöre auf mein leben
ich habe noch nie wieder eingesammelt
hast dann bist du behindert ich hab da 1
hingelegt und das sieht sogar hinter dir
wo du steht wäre einfach dass du hast ja
darauf wir wollen hier ganz toll wie
passieren kann ein geklautes liegt
hinter dir auf jeden fall wenn du hier
habe ich herausgefunden
ich habe mein schwert mit afterlife und
lud ihn gemacht das heißt es gibt zwei
optionen weil beide im widersprechen
sich bisschen aber eben eine schöne drop
chance das heißt entweder das pony vom
skelett also das direkte dass born
kannst oder du kriegst halten knochen
und habe zum beispiel bei dieser kurz
fraktion habe ich jetzt schon eine wird
das skelett kopf gerechnet
ja wenn man wir wollen ja knochen und
keine ritter skelettteile ja wie finster
alt so schnell wieder bissen stehst
kannst aber die knochen fahren aber man
muss dann immer wieder in die falle der
einlaufen damit man die sachen karriere
hast du ja genau aber die fahren ja
keinen fall die verbringen ja nicht gut
auf van nicht laufen ich habe jetzt eine
kräftig bauen sogar bekommen hat eine
kartbahn ja ich muss halt das einzig die
einzige sache an diesem blöden ding ist
einfach diese blöde aluminium ich dachte
das wäre das leichteste aber wir müssen
auch schon unsere folge beenden wie
kommen immer wieder kommst du auch mal
an diesem komischen eis links raus ja
immer alles wegen sie rege mich ob ich
laufe immer und ich habe das auch schon
mal abgebaut das hilft nicht nur das ist
aber scheiße das ist jetzt immer da
generiert laufen müssen wir beide
portale abbauen und dann ein neues
wurden einfach um ein portal in die
stadt setzen weiße muss man vielleicht
am nächsten folge
ja genau die folge setzt nämlich auf
jeden fall vorbei wenn es euch gefallen
hat liebe freunde da last eine bewertung
da und sonst schafft das auch
aufgenommen und dann sehen wir uns in
der nächsten folge wieder